113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 25
endogenous retroviruses how do we know
they really came from
viruses a little while back i published
a new animation
over on the stated clearly channel about
endogenous
retroviruses and these are retroviruses
so retroviruses are a special type of
virus that inserts its dna
into its host dna they actually start
out with an rna genome
convert that into dna insert it into the
cell
and when that cell reproduces the dna of
the virus will be reproduced as well and
so now both
the daughter cells have a copy identical
copy of the virus genome they can
make viruses pump out viruses and you
know
the virus reproduces well if they get
into a sperm cell
or an egg cell the child that develops
from that sperm or egg cell if a child
does
develop from them will have the virus
genome in every single cell of its body
and then it will pass the virus genome
on to its kids when it has kids
our genome the human genome is filled
with
virus genomes we call them endogenous
retroviruses because they are in us from
the start
so i did a video about this on the
stated clearly channel
and i've gotten a lot of questions about
some of the details that were not
covered or were sort of quickly
gone over in that animation it was a
very quick
introduction to endogenous retroviruses
and how they can be used
to make evolutionary trees because you
can actually see that
you know humans and chimps for example
share a bunch of endogenous retroviruses
and those were inserted before the chimp
humans split
so here are the questions well some of
the questions i've gotten a lot of them
i'll probably be doing a couple of
videos on this today i'm combining the
questions that i got from two different
people
one of them is youtube user mm how do we
recognize
that a portion of our dna is an old
contamination of a retrovirus
and then rodrigo asks could it be that
the things we call endogenous
retroviruses
are actually just parts of our dna that
god put there
at the moment of creation now once we
understand how it is that ervs are
recognized
ervs is endogenous retroviruses but it's
easier to say
so once you know how ervs are
recognizing the genome and you think
about it real carefully you'll realize
that
they can't tell us whether or not god
exists right
but they actually can tell us whether or
not they were put there
at the moment of creation or not so
yeah we we will examine those
questions here the information that i'll
be giving you
a lot of it comes from this book it's a
really great overview of just
you know the past 50 years of the study
of these things
and it's by john coffin stephen hughes
and harold
farmus john coffin actually was the main
researcher who advised me on that video
so it was really cool being at work with
him it turns out that if you read his
book
he doesn't really divide things like
like i do here but there are
11 different ways independent ways that
we can tell
that ervs really came from viruses so
the first one we're going to go through
all these one by one
the first one erv protein genes match
those
of retroviruses so here's
a little sketch of a retrovirus there's
the outline of a retrovirus
retroviruses have rna for their genome
you know i've got this this little
coiled up rna inside the actual virus
particle
it's going to go try to infect somebody
here and here i have the same genome
kind of laid out in schematic form
and i've got it divided into three big
chunks people will divide that the
genome into several different ways but i
divided it well
four chunks a little tail on the end
there a retrovirus has
a segment that codes for gag genes so
group antigen genes
and then a protease the group antigen
genes
those are the proteins that form a
little capsule
around the rna genome and some of them
bind actually to
the rna some of them form a shell around
it an extra coating around it
and then there's a protease which just
protease is a protein that breaks apart
other proteins
then there's another segment of the
genome that codes for the
polymerizing proteins there's a really
special
protein that retroviruses code 4 called
reverse transcriptase that's what
when when these when these viruses
reproduce they actually make a copy of
their
rna genome into dna and then they insert
that dna into the cell
they actually slice a part of your dna
pull it apart and they
insert their genome a dna copy of their
originally rna genome into your dna that
integration happens with this enzyme
called
integrase so you've got reverse
transcriptase and integrase are very
important then last but not least we
have the envelope genes
you've all heard of spike proteins by
now because of covid
these are the things that are on the
outside of something like the
coronavirus and also hiv has them the
flu has them
they are the things that stick to your
cells and allow the virus to
break into those cells they stick to the
outside of your cells
and help it you know get inside there's
a bunch of different envelope genes
that are coded for in a retrovirus
genome
and all of those are also found in ervs
so
these chunks of dna in our genome in the
human genome
that look just like virus genomes we
call them endogenous retroviruses
they have the gag pro genes the pole
genes
the end genes they've got all of them
and they're in
you know similar orders now if you start
reading papers on endogenous
retroviruses
you will find claims that you know the
human genome five percent of it
is endogenous retroviruses some people
say eight percent of it is
endogenous retroviruses and the reason
that you see different numbers in
different places
well some of it's because we've
discovered more of them as time goes on
we keep discovering new endogenous
retroviruses but
also another reason is that some people
might be only counting
an erv if it's a complete erv the whole
thing is there
some people might count it if it's only
partially there because what happens
over time is
these things mutate so i've kind of
darkened out some spots here to show
mutations and this this one is uh
it's pretty mutated in my sample here my
example here but
the whole thing's intact you'll have
sometimes you'll get a mutation that
knocks
out a big chunk of one and and then
you'll get some mutations
that are actually pretty common where
the the white part here
the part that i've drawn or white the
tail on the right will connect to the
tail on the left
and actually the whole thing will get
sliced out so that happens
but some people want to count any chunk
of an erv as an erv others only only
counted if the whole thing's intact
there's about again this number keeps
growing
but if you look at the databases right
now you'll find that there are about
9 000 complete ervs
that are over 90 still fully intact so
that are i mean there's absolutely no
question that these things are viruses
the remnants of viruses in the human
genome
and they're just there like all of us
have them so
it's pretty cool ervs are bookended by
long
terminal repeats just like retrovirus
insertions so
here i've got the long terminal repeats
up top is the erv that's in
in the human genome and then down below
is a retrovirus genome the rna genome
and it's got one long terminal repeat on
the right side here
it's got a tail there and what happens
is
this enzyme called reverse transcriptase
when it's making a dna copy
of the chain of rna it actually copies
that tail on both sides
and so the processed dna genome of the
virus
has two tails two long terminal repeats
that are identical to each other because
it actually
that enzyme uses one to make the
template for the other
so they're identical and then that gets
inserted into the victim's
genome that is an obvious sign that
there is a virus
insertion that's happened that you've
got these repeating stretches of dna on
either end
surrounding the virus protein
coding genes and those can be several
hundred
to over a thousand nucleotides long the
long terminal repeats
it just kind of depends from different
virus species to virus species how long
that's going to be
number three retroviral integrase
fingerprints
are found before and after each erv
so let me explain what that means
here i've i've colored in blue these
little uh erv
fingerprints or retrovirus fingerprints
and down below
i have the the retrovirus genome here
so this is the dna version the processed
version of the retrovirus
genome and below i have host dna before
insertion so this is a they haven't yet
been infected
by the virus well what's going to happen
is that that little
enzyme integrase that i've colored in
red here in my in my model
it's going to make a z-shaped slice in
your dna
and then it's going to separate your dna
so you've got this little jagged end
on both sides and if we were to zoom in
on that
it would look like this so that's that's
what the cut looks like
and then the virus dna will be inserted
between those two cuts
and if we were to zoom in just on those
two cuts and bring them in close to each
other
we see so here the white here
those are the long terminal repeats this
is the host's original dna with the
weird cut
going on there and whenever you have
a cut in your dna like this a break in
your dna there's an
enzyme that's going to run over and try
and fix it and it's going to use
whatever's here on the bottom it's going
to put the opposite on the top so
in my color scheme here i've shown that
green pairs with yellow
and blue pairs with red and so this
enzyme will actually
find the matching the missing pair and
rebuild
it and what happens is you get identical
little identical
copies of the pre-insertion site
on either end of the retrovirus
insertion
and let me just show you that these are
identical here so our sequence on the
top is yellow
then green then red then blue then
yellow then red
so it's it the way that this process
works
it ends up making two identical copies
on the ends of the retrovirus insertion
so down here below we see what a
retrovirus insertion looks like
up above we see what ervs look like in
our genomes these old
things that scientists tell us are the
remnants of ancient
viral infections well obviously they are
like they
they're identical not only do they have
the same protein-coding genes on the
inside of the genome
they have long terminal repeats and they
have these
little scars on the ends there so
that question that was asked could it be
that the things we call endogenous
retroviruses
are actually just parts of our dna that
god put there
at the moment of creation well
again i'm not going to tell you whether
or not you should believe that god
exists
you know there i've heard people say
that god is do is controlling
all things he's holding the universe
together or whatever so i suppose that
every time a virus inserts its genome
into a host
that was god doing that so i'm not going
to tell you whether or not this tells us
anything about the existence of god
but it does tell us that that these
these insertions did not happen
at the moment of creation
these things were put there by an
integrase
molecule and integrase molecules are
things that
retroviruses have so endogenous
retroviruses definitely were not there
since the beginning
for any endogenous retrovirus that you
find in the human genome if you go back
in time far enough maybe you have to go
back
to like before we were even primates but
you would find a time where
that specific endogenous retrovirus did
not exist
in the genome because it had not yet
been inserted there these things were
inserted after evolution was already up
and running
and our ancestors were evolving so
number four some ervs can still produce
full-fledged viruses
when cells are stressed so this is an
obvious
indication that ervs really did come
from viruses
this is a study on mice in this paper
they witness a retrovirus get turned
back on and start producing viral
particles
in pigs as well they've got some that
will produce viral particles
in live pigs the cells and live pigs are
actually
they they suppress viruses the viruses
aren't aren't usually made
but if you do a cell culture of pigs or
if you have like an organ
of a pig that you're keeping alive in a
petri dish or something it'll start to
express viruses because it gets stressed
it can't
it can't stop those viruses from forming
so they do
number five populations vary in number
of ervs
meaning they are continually inserted
and deleted
so what i mean there is that if you look
at any one species
of animal and then you look at different
populations of that species
you will find that they have different
numbers of ervs i mean most of them are
identical most of them are shared but
but sometimes you'll find like one or
two ervs in one population that are
unique to that population and only found
there
this is the case in chickens so here is
a study where people took a bunch of
different chicken breeds
and analyzed their dna and they found
that some of them had more
ervs and others well they found one that
had an
extra erb and what that means is that
either
a an erv was inserted in that population
since
humans started breeding chickens or it
means that that one
erv was somehow deleted in all other
populations of chickens
and so in this case because one
population of chickens had it and all
the other ones didn't
obviously the most parsimonious
conclusion is that
this is a new insertion in that one
population
this is another thing showing us that
endogenous retroviruses really do come
from viruses because
how would it have gotten an endogenous
retrovirus if it didn't come
from a retrovirus koalas are just loaded
with ervs
and any individual might have way more
ervs than another one
any family line i should say because
they have the viruses that that are
giving them
these new ervs they're highly active
they actually
make koalas sick and they get each other
sick and these things
just are really good at inserting
themselves in the germ lines
they're good at getting into sperm or
egg or you know newly fertilized
fetuses which makes it so they end up
getting in the germline
and they're passed from parent to child
and this is happening in koalas right
now
in humans it is not happening right now
so far as we can tell
but it was happening until fairly
recently probably
somewhere around six to ten thousand
years ago we still had
viruses that were active and actively
inserting themselves
into the reproductive lines of humans
and this is we know this because there
are certain populations that have
ervs and other populations do not when
we look for the
insertion sequence that little sequence
that's copied on
on either side of an erv or a retrovirus
when a retrovirus is inserted
we actually find the uninterrupted
insertion spot
in most humans and in certain groups we
find
the endogenous retrovirus there so that
tells us that
these things have been inserting
themselves until very recently
number six new erv insertions have been
directly observed in the lab so this is
a
an experiment that they did on mice
where they would just try and get mice
sick with viruses and see
if they would end up inserting
themselves into the germ line and
actually be
passable from parent to child you know
through reproduction
and the answer is yes they
in this one the sure way to make it
happen was to take
a freshly fertilized egg cell so sperm
has just fertilized it
and then exposed it to a virus and the
virus will end up in all of its cells
including the sperm or egg cells of that
of that developing fetus of that mouse
when it's finally born
and then it can pass on to its own
children
that virus so we know that it can happen
we know that retroviruses make it into
the genome
and we know how they do it because we've
played with it in the lab
we've seen this in chickens as well and
then another
study on mice this one was not lab
induced
so the scientist wasn't actually like
poking around and messing with things to
make sure that it would happen
what what we did is we we just were
breeding mice inbred mice for long
periods of time
because labs like to do experiments on
mice that are in bread because their
genomes are all identical so
if you do something on one mouse it's
sort of like doing it on another mouse
but periodically they will sequence the
genomes of their lab mice
and see if any big mutations have
happened
because if big mutations have happened
they need to
kind of you know hone those in so that
pretty much every mouse is identical
well they've found that in these labs
that we're doing very very careful
breeding
of their mice to not ever let any
contaminant from like a wild mouse get
in there
they found that within their own lab
over the course of 140 generations they
realized that
some viruses had inserted themselves in
some of their mice and not other ones
and they were inserted into the germline
they they had become endogenous
retroviruses in certain family lines of
their
originally inbred population now one of
the doubts that people have when they
first learn about ervs is
like how how could anything survive
getting
a virus permanently inserted into his
genome that's absurd
well we know that insertions
are quieted by the enzymes of the cell
so cells can actually shut these viruses
down
early on and that's been observed the
cells will
try and silence a virus make it so it
can't can't do its naughty virus
stuff even though it's in the genome
there and
yeah there's there's a bunch of studies
on that and what that is
these are adaptations that we must have
evolved because this is a common thing
we have these viruses that pop up in our
genomes and we have to deal with them
so these these adaptations exist in us
already number eight erv deletions have
been observed in the lab
another question that people often have
is if viruses can sometimes insert
themselves into a genome even if it's a
fairly rare event for that to happen
over time they should accumulate until
your entire genome was just nothing but
virus
genes and no
there are ways that these things can be
deleted
one way is for just a huge deletion in
your genome to happen which
deletions happen randomly from time to
time and that can cut out a huge chunk
of dna including the virus and that's
one way that there's
things can get cleaned up afterwards but
if you remember
i said that there are these long
terminal repeats on either end
of the insertion and those when a cell
is reproducing
those can get matched up with each other
and the virus can get
ripped out and deleted that way and
that's that's
much more of a precision cut it does
leave
one of the long terminal repeats behind
though so there's a lot of
single long terminal repeats that are
just like you'll find them all over the
genome
and here is an actual study where we
that was
observed happening in theory we knew
that was probably what was happening and
then we've actually seen it now in the
lab so
that's pretty cool number nine a mouse
erv
reverted into a full-fledged virus with
just one mutation so
again you know most of these ervs
especially the old ones
they're mutated to the point that they
don't work but
in this experiment there was a molecule
they were giving mice
and it turns out that a lot of the mice
that got this molecule would end up
expressing viruses endogenous
retroviruses
as if they were normal as if it were a
fresh infection and i'm like what
why is this molecule causing this
reaction well this molecule happens to
be highly mutagenic if you give it to
enough mice
some of them will happen to have a
mutation in
one of their retroviruses that turns it
back on there's a lot of endogenous
retroviruses in a mouse genome
and if you yeah if you go poking around
you're gonna accidentally turn one back
on you're gonna accidentally cause a
mutation
that reverses a mutation in the past
that disabled the virus
these are definitely viruses all right
now those of you who are listening
carefully
you might think that i just contradicted
myself because i said that most
animals have the ability to silence
endogenous retroviruses they can silence
these virus genomes and i just told you
here that
a single mutation turned an old mutated
endogenous retrovirus
back into a full-fledged retrovirus
shouldn't the body's cells have just
silenced it i mean how did this happen
well the silencing mechanisms
are only good at silencing the
endogenous retrovirus
in certain parts of the genome and it
only appears to work
in developing embryos so if you're an
adult and you get a retrovirus
you usually can't silence it it's a
special thing that babies can do
number 10 a virus genome was deduced
from human
erv sequences and built in the lab and
actually worked as a real virus
so here's here's the study on that what
they did is they looked at a bunch of
endogenous retroviruses that were
closely related in humans
and they got what is called a consensus
genome
for that group of viruses we look at
them we say oh
look there's a mutation that this one
has and none of the other ones have
therefore if we edit it back to be the
same as the one that all the other ones
have
we've healed this endogenous retrovirus
it's now more similar to the actual
virus that originally infected our human
ancestors
and they did this you know they had
several different
endogenous retroviruses that were
closely related to look at and
to do this and they were able to correct
every single one of the mutations that
had happened
since insertion or at least enough of
them that the thing
worked they put it inside human cells
in petri dishes so they didn't infect a
human with it
thank goodness it can infect human cells
it really infects them and it really
spreads from cell to cell
so that's crazy we just we we brought a
virus back to life
from the dead from extinction yay
just what we need more viruses and then
last but not least new erv proteins and
new erv regulators
can give immediate benefits to hosts and
this
answers the question a lot of people
have you know why wouldn't natural
selection just delete these things
why is it that these things end up in
our genomes
well it's because oftentimes they can be
beneficial
and there are some really cool studies
on this sometimes
it's actually good to get a virus
permanently stuck
in your genome sometimes the details on
this
are pretty cool and they this deserves
its own video
so i'm not gonna go over these in depth
right now but
you can just take a look at these papers
if you want to read them on your own if
you're if you're
extra ambitious or you can wait until
next week when i talk about them myself
and yeah it's really cool it's really
cool what what these things can do
for a host if the host can stop
them from actually producing full-on
virus
particles full-on infection you know
that's going to be
detrimental to them so yeah endogenous
retroviruses can
be beneficial let me just wrap this up
here because i've been going for a while
how do we recognize that a portion of
our dna is an old
contamination of a retrovirus well
the 11 things i just showed you that's
how and then could it be that the things
we call endogenous retroviruses are
actually just parts of our dna that god
put there
at the moment of creation the answer to
that is no
whether or not god exists again that's
up to you if you want to believe
whatever
but these retrovirus insertions these
endogenous retroviruses
certainly were not there from the
beginning they
have been inserting themselves into our
ancestors
as we started our evolutionary journey
this is a continual thing we know this
because of the signatures
of integrase which is the enzyme that
integrates them into
the genome of a host and we know this
because
different populations of the same
species will have
a few uh endogenous retroviruses that
other
populations don't have that tells us
that these things are continually being
inserted
into our genomes
so next question
you